hello and welcome to this video plug EMG
Buell jug you later check you later okay
so and playing in London system for a
change okay I get something interesting
quickly interest interesting let's get
some space that cannot be too bad
gaining all that space just have to make
sure it's not making too many Volvo yeah
really a lot lots of porn or something
he takes which is interesting mean to be
three maybe p 6 whoa that looks very
ugly
hmm I wonder just 92 I guess he's not
taking this who Edwards castle long and
play for the big advantage in
development maybe I do 96
95 yum that's extremely annoying move
no not much I can do here and if I go in
for I might plunder d4l that way
I would like to go if all in this
position shut his bishop out I don't
want to trade maybe I still should do
this and all night in five plays Bishop
86 it's a bit weird but maybe that's not
too bad it should be a six
yeah right he can play no doesn't work
that's a good move yeah long casual Sam
I should really forget about this idea
whenever I can't for long and greenpoint
openings I'm always in trouble this is
really what it is every single game even
in cases where it should be objectively
good I'm in trouble and this is probably
not one of them I'm not sure what you
should do here it takes is how I see
takes or queen takes both both might
make perfect sense this one okay
so before Quincy seven is the point okay
and i really want to close that bishop
for the time being take it off I've
and you I know that looks a bit strange
but I have an idea why doesn't click on
system I'm just calculating stuff that
never happens Wow okay
[Music]
he's got Bishop before always that's
super-annoying covering everything and
retakes on default also a bit of a self
in maybe just be sure to see form time
warning
f no movie unbelievable not a single
move and now look cook whatever at four
probably kills me no this one okay
Queenie three editors just a rockin game
[Music]
just opening mayor okay I don't believe
in this just one bit for black with no
space and nothing else but I shouldn't
care for long I mean as you shouldn't
problem so g5 is already ending the game
here I just a thought I thought about
this but I simply forgot that I can take
with this and at the end of the game
simply g6 comes and this is also
completely unplayable for age six and
I'm just meeting Amir ok and cannot work
this kind of opening you have no space
and cash flow right into this which is
that muffin knight c6 which I didn't see
my position becomes really difficult and
then he started to play really good move
I mean so if all was wrong look
completely normal I have desire oh
that's of course that's a good move
yeah I know it's got good space him
that's better now before was a bit crazy
the turn down they played that well I
mean it's just what it is the opening
once was unplayable simply but after
that it was good this is just rotten
maybe if he doesn't cancel shore and
counseling short is just after g5 losing
more or less can this is more or less
losing if it doesn't cancel short I mean
I must be better as I mean quite
obviously but it's not like completely
disastrous a six or something else now
whenever I can so long in any default
winning edge usually ends up badly it's
just what it is okay thanks for watching